[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we had an opportunity to talk to
marcus smart and uh he uh had a cause he
lost his brother and mother to cancer
motivating him to get involved with
programs that help people of color in
the fight against cellular diseases and
he wants people to sign up for the
national blood stem cell registry
and i had not talked to him in a long
time
and i remember oklahoma state good
player got involved uh with a fan
and there was an altercation and uh he
seemed to get a reputation off of that
and this is one of those interviews
where i wasn't sure i wanted to do it
because i didn't know if it was going to
be entertaining and here we are in
september and then i thought okay mark
is smart there was possibility he was
going to get traded to the nets and
kevin durant was going to be involved
and jaylen brown and marcus smart were
going to be traded
and then i thought you know he's
guarding steph curry like there were
story lines i thought okay even though
it's football season
i thought let's try it and marcus joined
us right after the show we had a chance
to talk to him and uh he was in his
house and and there's a weight room in
the back
and of course that's where i started
because i asked him how much he's
benching nowadays here's mark is smart
so yeah it is uh i'm actually not
benching a lot um
you don't want to bench too much um
because you don't you don't want to lose
the flexibility that you have so
you know but i could probably bench 185
at least 15
the strongest guy in the nba
would be who probably not the strongest
of probably one of the strongest guards
for sure okay but who is the strongest
guy in the nba if you put him in a
weight room they'd put on a show
oh
man you definitely gotta go with lebron
just the way he takes care of his body
um uh you definitely could tell you know
he has the strength but you got guys
i believe zion is a guy i believe myself
is a guy um i mean you got a lot of guys
in there that that you can put in so
it's kind of hard but then again you
also got guys that may look like they're
pretty strong and somebody else can come
out there and not lift them so it just
really depends
who's the guy you run into and you go
damn that hurts
oh man for me
dwight dwight howard was one of those
guys i've ran into him a few times and
on the court he set a screen on me and
i'm just like man what's going on uh the
joker jokic
nicola he's he's a big guy as well
strong um solid solid body so when you
run into them you feel every every every
every hit that they that they put on
yourself
who's the guy that you're still trying
to figure out
how is that guy so good offensively
wow
i would probably say for me
the
peyton pritchard on my team peyton
pritchard because he's so small and when
you look at him um you know you just
like there's no way
you know he can do the things that he's
doing and he comes out there and you're
like hot like you're just trying to
figure out how is he able to to to get
the space that he needs to get his shot
off how is he able to hold his own
defensive end being so small so
i have to go with peyton richmond but
you understand why the joker is so great
or lucas so great or
like it just feels like whenever i watch
the joker i go god it doesn't it looks
really simple it doesn't do anything
really interesting
yeah i mean those type of guys like luca
and joker you know they've been playing
professionally and against professionals
since they were like 14 15 years old
so they were very well worth uh
rehearsing and you know coming to the
league and being a professional and and
knowing how to play so when they got
here it was they've been playing for so
long as a professional but it just came
natural to them and that's why it looks
so easy for them because they've been
doing it for so long
how do you know you've done a good job
on steph curry
[Laughter]
how do you know you've done a good job
on steph curry oh man
when he's not rocking you to sleep
when he's not doing his little
[Laughter]
sleep
he's rocking you to sleep you obviously
didn't do too well
what's that feeling like
ah it's
it's brutal it's it's not a great
feeling it's it's um
[Music]
yeah um it's it's it hurts let's just
say that it hurts but is it like he's
paid to be the you know the best shooter
ever so there's no shame
in that when you're covering him you
know he's going to score
yeah and see that that might be true for
most people but when you see yourself as
getting paid as one of the best
defenders
anybody's calling you you're going to
take your personality all right
definitely the better shooters if not
the best shooter
so
he's going to score a little bit but i
definitely take it a little personally
who talks to you during a game the most
myself probably myself i probably say i
myself talks to me the most and i'm
constantly talking to myself
um
constantly trying to make sure you know
my teammates um
then i know what i need to do for my
teammates to get my teammates going you
know there's times where you know i
might make a dumb play and i'm talking
to myself the other than myself
probably swearing at myself and you know
just trying to keep myself motivated
we're talking to marcus smart the
celtics guard how is your boston accent
uh my boss is an accent i think i think
it's coming a long way you know i'm
saying i'll be down by the hobbit i'm
saying up like this i think i think i
got it when i go to my car i think i do
a good job
but i always hear mark is smart a mark
is smart marcus smart as my name is
perfect for the boston accent but when
you go back home do you ever bring that
accent back with you
oh no oh no
i was gonna say
how would your boys feel when they uh if
they heard you and you went back home oh
man to be honest uh it's had it
it has actually happened before and my
boys just kind of looked at me weird and
funny and then they kind of tell me i
switched up and then about 10 minutes to
20 minutes and then to our conversation
the accent's gone and i'm back down
south again and my accent's back but it
definitely comes off a little bit okay
you hear the rumors in the off-season
maybe kevin durant's coming to boston
you know that jayson tatum jalen brad
somebody's going to be involved and you
so
how do you deal with that when your name
is floating and you have no control over
it
how do you deal with it uh for me
how i would deal with it is you know
like you said we have no control over
you know so for me to focus on what i
don't have any control over all he's
gonna do is drive me crazy insane
probably make me lose focus so for me i
try to focus on the things i can't
control like
staying healthy you know taking care of
my body getting the work in so whatever
does happen i'm prepared for it anyway
and that's kind of how i stay and kind
of keep me focused when all these rumors
and voices but did you get a hold of
jaylen brown or jason tatum
since their their mention in you know
the trade talks
we actually i've actually trained with
both of those who are not jt but i've
seen him in l.a we were all trained in
la and i worked out with jb a couple of
times um
never once did we talk about detroit
at least they never said anything to me
about it and like i said uh they've done
a great job of being professionals
um handling it well and focusing on what
they're supposed to focus on they can
control so
if they
have any concerns or whatever i know
nothing about they haven't showed to me
you're around them and nobody that's the
elephant in the room marcus
yeah
it is but you know i've been knowing
jalen and jason for a very long time
you know we're the core group of guys on
this celtics team we've been playing
who's been through a lot so
a lot of times you know we're just
focused on you know um
not taking things for granted you know
we have we had an opportunity to to make
it to the finals we have an opportunity
to to hopefully do it again this season
with a great group of guys so for us we
focus on what we control and
unfortunately that side of the uh the
business is something we can't control
and we try to lead that up to the guys
we think
did you watch the game film of the
finals
definitely did
literally about approximately a week
after
we played i watched some film and i was
on youtube and
every lick of
tape i can get and just watching it and
crying myself to sleep
myself
tell me what you're doing with uh be the
match because i think it's something
great that you're working on and uh a
great cause and it's certainly personal
to you
definitely you know i'm partnering with
and and partnering with affleck and be
the match to to you know
bring awareness
become a donor and help you know this
this
disease that we have
in cancer in the blood diseases that's
sickle cell
and you know just really trying to close
the gap on the disparity of you know um
when it comes to being able to find a
donor for
four people uh especially
as black and african american in the
communities of those to be able to find
a match more suitable for those for for
the sick people that need it um
and you know affleck and be the match is
perfect because they help
like i said close that gap with things
that that when it comes to funding um
that most might not have and you know we
all need a little bit of help and so you
know it's great to be able to to be able
to partner with two groups that are
doing something that i feel very
strongly about has a very impact in my
life and what i've been through
it's great to talk to you and uh good
luck this upcoming season
i'd like i'd like to you know maybe uh
go
one-on-one with you maybe if i get 10
try could i score on you if i got 10
tries
not make it take it i just get the ball
10 times
10 times could you score
it depends
it depends on how nice i am that day oh
yeah have you ever let somebody score in
the nba
i have i have
not not a lot but yeah it's sometimes
you let guys it's certain certain
certain causes like it's been times
where i've had to let people score
because i've been in foul trouble didn't
want to get into foul trouble so i just
let it go then it's sometimes where i'll
let you score just to
prove it to me and so it's it just
depends but for you if i'm on a good day
having a good day
because i don't break ankles i lightly
sprain them just to let you know okay
i'm not gonna break your ankles but if
you leave me open
you pay the price i've been called the
klay thompson of sports talk radio
i like it there we go i like i love it
just don't get too close to me like let
me have an open jumper and i'll make it
marcus all right
here we go hey great to talk to you
again thank you you as well thank you
it's marcus smart the celtics i really
liked him
i didn't know much about him i mean i
knew his career but as far as a
personality and i thought you know what
give him a shot you know we're not in
boston so may not seem interviewed that
often usually
it's uh going to be the coach or the
star player but uh defensive player of
the year and i thought that uh you know
he was kind of light and willing to give
you some opinions here so i like that